[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
a bit of a different type of video in
the midst of all the galaxy s10 hype so
last year i did my smartphone awards for
2018 and that's always a mix of uh a
bunch of objective reasoning which
phones are best plus a little bit of
opinion injected in there for some
discretion as well but what i didn't
have in that awards was a favorite
smartphone of the year to use category
but hindsight 2020 i kind of think my
favorite phones of last year to use that
i ended up using most often
came down to it probably a toss-up
between pixel 3 xl and oneplus 6t and
there were plenty of other good phones
that year but a lot of you've noticed in
the past couple videos when i'm just
using whatever daily phone it is it's
sort of switched back and forth between
oneplus 6t and pixel and oneplus and
pixel again that's because in real life
i was getting fed up with one and
switching to the other and getting like
missing the other one and switching back
and then going back and forth it's kind
of a blessing and a curse having both of
them available to me so why was i
switching back and forth between these
two main phones so often for me really
it had two major things to do with the
pixel and it's not the notch
that would be the performance and the
camera so to step away from the oneplus
for a second on the pixel the camera is
a plus that's first of all the pixel 3
camera consistently takes the best
quality photos of any smartphone i've
ever tried so far and it's kind of not
even close but that's a big but the
performance issues including even in the
camera app itself have stuck with the
pixel from last year so here's the thing
there really are actually two
best cameras there's the camera that
takes the absolute best quality images
and then there's the best overall camera
experience which is a combination of
image quality and speed and a bunch of
other things so pixel keeps for me
winning best
camera quality it's that best camera and
i love that about it but i would give
best camera experience to some other
phones the iphone for its speed or for
its video or for samsung for its wide
angle that it just added or the mate 20
pro all kinds of others do the
experience better especially with speed
so that was what was so disappointing so
i've had all kinds of various lag and
performance issues with this pixel after
a couple of months which is
disappointing for a second year in a row
especially when google makes this phone
i mean you would think they have all
sorts of control over it but when i have
some other apps open or when things like
music apps are working in the background
or gps apps etc one of the early bugs
would be it would just quit that
background app whenever i open the
camera and that bug's since been fixed
but there are still issues that are not
totally gone
i'm thinking maybe four gigs of ram
actually really isn't enough so the
oneplus the 6t this is the mclaren
edition by the way that i've been using
for a couple weeks and i really like it
the performance has been fantastic a
plus performance actually it's the
fastest android phone i've ever used but
and that's another big but the camera
not so great
so if the if the pixel had a better
performance more consistently this would
be my far and away favorite phone or if
the oneplus had a better camera then
this would be by far and away my
favorite phone it kind of comes down to
that feeling that there's just never any
perfect phone so the dilemma is pixel a
plus camera c plus performance or
oneplus 6t
a plus performance c plus camera which
do you choose
and for me that was why i kept going
back and forth now i got to give some
credit to the google camera apk
for those wondering it does make a
difference so you can install what's
essentially a port of the google camera
app on the oneplus 6t instead of the
oneplus camera app and using that turns
out it's really good it gets you better
dynamic range better contrast and
exposure and even white balance more
consistently and even better detail and
better low light shots and then you get
night sight built in which works pretty
well too but it's still nowhere near the
pixel's actual camera in the detail
department and overall image quality is
still clearly going to the pixel i mean
maybe it's unfair to compare it to the
pixels camera because nothing quite
matches up to the pixel but by itself
this app brings the camera from a c plus
to a b b plus so i'll link it below
because i think every oneplus 6t owner
should know about it now that's of
course not the only difference here's
some thoughts i've had on some other
little things between the two over the
past couple months the display on the
pixel 3 is definitely better than on the
oneplus but it's not massively different
enough to make a huge difference to me
you would think for me you know a pixel
peeper a larger higher resolution
display would automatically take the
advantage over the 6t but then again the
6t has a way less obtrusive notch but
honestly at this point neither of the
notches
bother me that much so the display was a
net zero it wasn't a deal breaker at all
for me in either direction but for you
it might be different matter of fact
most people will agree that the oneplus
6t has one of the notches that's easiest
on the eyes for any phone to come out
last year and it wasn't too weird
interfacing with most apps it fits
neatly in the notification bar and
didn't get in the way of icons so if
you're one of those people that really
hates notches then that could actually
be a big swinging point for you build
quality is also different between these
two in materials and construction of
these two phones the batteries are
different sizes one of them is water
resistant the other isn't one of them
has wireless charging and the other
doesn't and that turned into one of the
main things i really missed about the
oneplus 6t is it not having wireless
charging
and a lot of other phones coming out now
just generally you kind of expect a
flagship to have wireless charging and i
missed it now i know they love their
dash charging and their fast charging is
super good but i have wireless chargers
in all kinds of convenient places and it
was just really disappointing to not be
able to use them as i use the oneplus 6t
so that's the one thing i miss and now
it looks like oneplus is probably also
not going to have wireless charging in
the oneplus 7 at least according to
recent reports
also pretty disappointing then the
speaker of course i gotta give that edge
to the pixel as well you know anytime
you try to get rid of bezels you
basically have to sacrifice speakers but
the one upside to the pixel having some
of the thickest bezels in the game is it
still has huge stereo front-facing
speakers while everyone else's including
one pluses are pretty average at best
and then there's the operating system so
oxygen os versus pixels android and as i
said in my review of the phones pixel's
android is smarter it has more useful
features like call screening and the now
playing song identification and top shot
and night sight in the camera etc etc
the list goes on but oxygen os isn't
exactly slacking with features either
it's it's fast and then it's got things
like the shelf it has dark mode it has
dash charging it's clean and it also
gets frequent software updates it's
ahead of most of the rest of the skin
phones even if it's right behind the
pixel so it's got lots of useful stuff
on its own so what it really comes down
to and the point of this video is i
really enjoyed using each of these
phones in the respective times that i
use them for different reasons
but the question of is the oneplus 6t
this one better than the pixel 3 xl
objectively no
it really isn't actually like if you
look at it on paper you get wireless
charging you get water resistance you
get a better camera you get a better
display you get all these exclusive
software features better build
it's a better phone than the oneplus 6t
but
the experience of using the 6t
was
often better than the experience of
using the 3. which is even more
impressive because of the price
difference the 200 plus dollar
difference between these two phones
which is even more if it isn't the
mclaren edition which by the way just
has two extra gigs of ram it's not a
crazy huge difference in specs but i
have enjoyed this phone so for those
asking all seven or eight of you
wondering why i keep switching back and
forth it's the performance that keeps
pushing me away from the pixel
and then the camera that keeps pushing
me back easily my next favorite phone to
use is oneplus 6t because it's got all
these amazing features and it's got
excellent performance but then i go to
take pictures and i remember how good
this camera is and then i switch back
and then i'm disappointed by the
performance again and so you can see how
that vicious cycle's played out either
way we'll see oneplus 7 and pixel 4
this year in 2019 along with a bunch of
other phones i mean this is an exciting
year for phones it sort of turned out
for those who are asking if we've
reached peak smartphone now we have a
folding phone launching this year we saw
all that stuff at mobile world congress
and then we have new patents for a
motorola folding phone and all these
other flagships we haven't even expected
yet the note 10 is totally under the
radar uh it'll be a good year for phones
but let me know what you're looking
forward to we've got plenty of videos
coming up on all that stuff including of
course the s10 review so let me know
what you guys are into either way thanks
for watching this one
talk to you guys later
peace